Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
We have another first look
for House of the Dragon Season 2
episodes with a teaser
for some really important scenes between
Aegon the second and Larys
Strong ser weird foot stuff himself,
who has been elevated to the Green Council
since the end of season one.
So we'll break it all down.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
They just finished filming season two,
so we'll get some more trailer footage,
some teasers by later this year
to The other really good news recently
is that HBO kind of laid out
that they were about to fast
track season three
because of the writers strike ending.
They want the showrunner,
Ryan Condal George R.R.
Martin, to get Season
three going as fast as possible,
Which is great
because it means there's a good chance
that it could get out within
a year of season two and no more waiting.
Billions of years, eons between seasons.
But recently you may have seen the teaser
in your feeds.
The scene between Aegon
the second Larys strong.
We got part of this scene,
a little teaser,
the two of them that takes place
later in the season probably going to be
episode five, just based on
what's happening in the actual scene.
this is meant to happen after the battle.
Brooks rest
after what's going on in this scene
here with the Green Army
marching through the streets
of King's Landing in a big celebration
of their victory in the recent battle.
The interesting thing, too, is that
we actually got this scene from the wrap
celebration like it was them celebrating
them, finishing all the episodes.
They filmed them out of order.
The last big thing we know that they were
filming was the Battle of Rooks, France.
but that's going to take place
in the middle of the season.
Not at the end of the season.
zoom in enhanced at the top here.
This is the actual scene.
And this quote is taken
between Aegon and Larys Strong.
It's Larys's
congratulating him, stroking his ego
as much as possible, telling him
what a special little boy he is.
Larys's says.
You've already written yourself
into legend.
You survived Dragon Fire.
that's meant to be a line of dialog
taken directly from the Fire and Blood
book about the Targaryen history
from after the battle at Looks Rest in
what's happened is that during the battle
Aegon is gravely wounded but survives.
So he's lying there on the edge of death,
recovering.
And Larys Strong comes along
to congratulate him on not dying.
Like, Hey, you're alive. This is great.
Basically trying to stroke his ego
by saying that his victory and survival
will become legendary, which it does not.
in the whole line about surviving
Dragon Fire is layers
leaning into the whole idea.
The Targaryens
believe themselves to be fireproof.
Historically Targaryens
believe themselves to essentially be
dragons themselves, and thus that gives
them an immunity to fire.
Here's the thing, though.
That's not totally true.
Even though they portrayed things
a little bit differently
during the original Game of Thrones
series,
the difference there is that
we didn't see that many targaryens
there've been a number of times
in the books that have proven that wrong.
Also on that original Game of Thrones
series,
for example right now in what's happening
in House of the Dragon, Daimon Targaryen,
who's
one of the most old school targaryens
there is, He'll go on all day
about how they're dragons themselves.
And this is what his wound
looks like from a flaming arrow
that he took
during a battle in season one.
Notice his skin is severely burned,
clearly not immune to fire.
way back in the original Game of Thrones
series during season one, dinners.
His brother Viserys
the second named for Rhaenyra.
father, Viserys the first.
he always kept spouting on
about his temper.
Don't wake the dragon dangerous.
And he's definitely not immune to fire.
The best example
of this phenomenon, though,
when people talk about targaryens
not being immune to fire is the Targaryen
prince who tried to drink wildfire
unsuccessfully.
this is actually during the time of Dunk
egg real named egg
on the fifth Targaryen
who became the eventual king of westeros
a little over 100 years after
what's happening on Dance of the Dragons.
they'll actually be covering that period
during the Tales of Dunk
Egg during the next Game of Thrones
prequel series they just announced.
The current title for
that is The Knight of the Seven Kingdoms.
I think it'll premiere
in like the next two,
maybe three years,
depending on how fast they go.
So we might actually get to see that
Targaryen Prince try
to drink the wildfire
and just get burn alive.
it should also be noted that wildfire
is a different type of fire than Dragon.
Fire is also a different type of fire
than regular fire.
Like when you burn wood,
Wildfire is a chemical concoction Dragon
Fire is like a totally different magical
kind of fire, like it's actual magic.
According to George R.R. Martin.
it burns way,
way hotter than natural fire.
Wildfire is more like the Game of Thrones
version of Greek fire.
That's only sounds like the title of a
YouTube video, like Top ten Types of Fire
Inside Game of Thrones.
either way, it's been proven.
Not all targaryens are immune to fire.
that was just meant to be dangerous.
And when you see other people
being immune to fire like the Night King,
that's because of magic.
George R.R.
Martin also said that as near
as being immune to fire
was meant to be a special thing
in the Song of Ice and Fire,
also implying some ancient dragon magic.
But here's the thing, though.
Even though a lot of them lie
about being immune to fire when they say
that they're all part dragon,
like the Targaryens say that they're part
dragon, even Daimon boasting about it.
They're not totally wrong about that.
part of the whole reason
why Targaryens and people of Valerian
Blood mostly can bond with dragons
is because of the special magical
techniques used by the ancient
Valyrian blood mages in the freehold.
way back during season one,
when Alicent was younger and Viserys
was telling her all these stories
about his model of the Valyrian freehold.
He was talking about the Anogrion.
This is where the ancient Valerian bloodmages
practiced their secret arts,
part of their now lost techniques,
their lost magic was intermingling.
Dragon DNA in the DNA of the greater
valyrian houses in the freehold.
So essentially they were making people
descended from those bloodlines.
Part Dragon.
now. Not
every valyrian could bond with dragons.
It was only meant to be
the greater houses,
but there were many of them
in the freehold at its peak.
So you have to imagine over many thousands
of years, thousands of them having
thousands of bastards in the bloodline
just sort of dilutes from there on on
and you don't need to be a pure blood
to bond with dragons,
you only need to be loosely
related to them,
so essentially the real reason
why dragons obey them
and bond with them is because
they're sensing the dragon DNA in them.
And there's also a little bit of magic
kind of mixed
in with that
because of the blood mages in the Dragons.
Think of the targaryens
now in present day as their own, like,
oh, you're just like us. no.
On top of that
they also form familial attachments
with them
from the time that they're hatched.
That's why
they put dragon eggs in the babies
cribs to start that as early as possible.
So when they're born,
the Dragons will imprint on them.
But also the fact that they're sensing
sort of like the low level dragon DNA
inside them also helps that a lot.
this is also why after a dragon rider
dies, their dragon can be claimed
and bonded with by someone else
because the dragon is also sensing
the dragon DNA in that new person
and thinks of them as one of their kind.
Like, Oh, you're cool, we can be friends.
but when Dragons bond with humans,
the Dragons also take on personality
traits of their writers.
so for instance Damian's dragon
crack sees has a personality
like Daemon's very mercurial They also say
this is true of like dogs in real life,
even though the way they portray dragons.
On the Game of Thrones
series House of the Dragon is a little bit
more like large cats
they're actually three main houses
in Game of Thrones.
Who can say
that they're a valerian descent?
The target audience, obviously
the Valerian, who were a seafaring family
that didn't originally have the ability
to bond with dragons.
the reason why
some people inside their family can bomb
a dragons like Laenor, like Bella,
like Rina is because over time you have
a lot of aliens marrying with targaryens
so they get part of that
dragon bonding DNA intermingled that way.
so for instance, that's why Corliss
Valerian cannot bond with dragons.
But his son Laenor could same thing
with Daemon and his daughters, Baela
and Raina. Baila and Raina would have gotten
the dragon bonding DNA no matter what,
because their mother, Laena,
also got it from Princess Rhaenys's.
it was just a plus
that their father was also Daemon.
It's kind of the same situation
with how Celtic are like.
There are lesser House
of Valyrian descent,
but they do not have dragons,
but some of them in their family
can Boma Dragons
most of though for the same reasons
because of long term intermarriage
with Targaryens other ancient Bulgarians
that did have dragon bonding DNA. But.
In present day, the whole idea is that
the entire realm was terrified of dragons.
They were like nuclear weapons
controlled solely by the targaryens
for the most part.
so all of them leaned on that
as a way to keep the realm in line.
Like the threat of dragons.
A lot of time was more effective
than actually taking a dragon
and burning down
one of the different realms
also cause we less collateral damage
that's changed in present day
because of the Dance of the Dragons,
because that's a civil war
within the House.
And both sides have dragons.
so this part of the reason why you have
Laura strong boasting trying to pump him
up saying that he's immune to fire
because he is Targaryen,
even though clearly it's not true.
one of the other funny things
about the Greens too,
is that they're relying heavily
on the Targaryen brand
to legitimize or to strengthen Aegon's
claim to the Iron Throne
when really Alicent actually can't stand
all the Targaryen stuff.
The showrunners explained the way
that they played her characters
during the time jump.
Essentially,
she found religion in a much bigger way
than she had before Her family.
The Hightower is historically had always
had a very close relationship
with the faith of the seven.
their seat of power is Old Town
in Old Town, who used to be
the main capital city of Westeros
until Aegon's conquest.
So for many hundreds of years after
the faith of the seven
was brought to Westeros by the Vandals,
the original grates
that the original high scepter
were in Old Town near the high towers.
though
even though in present day of Allison
leaning heavily
into the faith of the seven
trying to get away from all this Targaryen
stuff, the Greens are relying so heavily
on the brand and also on the idea
that Aegon is the oldest living male heir.
this is part of the reason
why he was named Aegon in the first place.
Why they use Aegon
the Conquerors crown during his coronation
and why they gave him the Blackfire
valyrian sword.
If aegon's ancestral blade To be fair
though, when he was named Aegon Alicent
when she was much, much younger, wasn't
thinking about all this battle
for the succession stuff.
Most of that started with Otto Hightower,
the minute the Aegon was born,
like the wheels and his head
started turning like, okay,
we need to find a way
to put this boy on the iron throne.
So when present day Otto Hightower wants
Aegon the second to seem to the people
like to the populace is the actual second
coming of Aegon the conqueror
So he's got his name he's wearing the same
crown made of Valerian steel no less
and he's got his same valerian sword
the other thing about that
Valerian saw too,
is that that had always been passed down
from Aegon
the Conqueror to each successive king.
That's why Viserys had it even though
there is no way he looks strong enough
to swing that around,
he was way more of a history nerd
than he was a big fighter
in reality, in present day,
even though you have this giant battle
for the succession,
the dance of the Dragons,
most of the greens don't
actually care about the actual valerian
costumes are triggering cultural practices
or the law.
That's why Alice never really cared
about all the businesses stories,
the villain history
or his toy model replica.
The brewery in Freehold, most of the time
she just sat there and humored him
because she wanted to make him happy
you know, on the other side of that,
what she was getting out of it,
at least at first when she was younger.
Like these types of scenes,
according to the showrunner,
the way they played
it was that the series was
one of the few people inside the Red Keep
that actually seemed like
he saw her and treated her with respect,
like an actual person.
whereas people like her father, Otto
Hightower, pretty much everybody else,
for the most part, everywhere, either
treated her like she didn't exist at all
or she existed to be a piece of property
that they just expected
to do whatever anyone told her to do.
now is the and present day
with the dance of the Dragons.
Everything's completely changed ba.
Bringing things back around
to sort of weird foot stuff
is we have a couple of the scenes of him
at the Red Keep at Herron Hall.
And since the end of season one, Alicent
has elevated him to the Green Council
as the master of whispers,
Essentially the Crown spymaster,
that was the role that the series had.
He was master of whispers to air is the
second the Mad King before Robert Bratton.
actual position was created
after the time of Aegon
the Conqueror, though
it was make for the crew who started it.
And it was one of his wives called Tiana.
The Tower supposedly his most feared wife.
She became the first one
basically doing the same thing the various
did that Layer Strong is doing now,
you know on the other side of this
to talk about Rhaenyra side of things
misery through her association
with Daemon has become Rhaenyra
as mistress of whispers.
the other big thing with his characters
that layers has also become the Lord
a parent whole after he killed his father
and brother back in season one.
but that happened much earlier.
And it was more of an automatic hereditary
title.
Being named to
the Green Council was a bigger favor.
Alicent paid him back for in exchange
for giving her information
on pretty much everything
since she was younger.
In this moment here, like
this is where their relationship bAegon
she basically owed him a lot
and he had a ton,
a ton of dirt on everyone, including her.
That's also why he was forcing
to do all the weird foot stuff.
Basically, him lording his power over her
cannot wait
to see what kind of weird depraved stuff
he makes her do in season two.
Pose all your theories about that
in the comments below.
the other big thing about this teaser
for the scene between Aegon and Lares
is it is notable because it pays off
Helena's Dragon dream from season one,
the last ring has no legs,
meaning Aegon can no longer walk.
that they finally finished filming,
we might get another teaser trailer
pretty soon.
So of course they'll do videos
for everything they wind up releasing.
We do know that season
two episode one will be Blood and Cheese.
I might do a longer video
about them at some point,
but if you do have any bonus video
requests
or questions about any of the characters,
the plot let me know in the comments.
They also just released a teaser
for the white Walkers and the whites.
Coming back in season two.
Click here to watch that
and click here for that Game of Thrones
Knight of the Seven Kingdoms Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!